I imagine that we will um see and hear
something from Vladimir Putin fairly
soon but it will be all in the uh vein
of him continuing his normal work
nothing to see here you know no Ruffles
no feathers ruffled in the Kremlin I I
think that will be the image that
Vladimir Putin will be trying to project
I doubt that we'll see much from yevgeni
pregozian uh the last pictures we did
see of him were on Saturday night when
he was waved off in a car from rostov to
Cheers a lot of people there clearly
supporting Wagner troops and is
presumably on route to Belarus where he
will probably for the time being sit
quietly and as for Sergey shoigu I don't
think that we should have anticipated
that he would have been unseated uh
certainly not by Putin although that was
what yevgeni prigon wanted and I think
the writing was on the wall for that
um from the last couple of weeks or
months in fact the whole basis for all
of this was that Sergey shoigur had
demanded that the mercenary groups
operating in Ukraine and there are quite
a fair few of them not just Wagner come
under the control of the ministry of
defense and sign contracts with the
ministry of Defense to try and keep some
kind of order over all these disparate
bodies of fighting men but also I think
very much to keep yevgeny pregojin under
control and Ashoka would not have done
that without the decision or backing of
Vladimir Putin and that's what annoyed
pregojin and uh about 10 days ago he
came into Moscow with demands of his own
saying I'm not going to sign contracts I
want to have a Wagner representative as
Deputy defense minister I want Sergey
shoigu to appear on Boards of Wagner
meetings and that was clearly not
palatable either to shoigu or to Putin
and I think it was Putin's mistake that
he allowed things to escalate over the
intervening week and didn't stop
precaution in his tracks but he doesn't
speak directly to pregojin he's always
sort of kept him at arm's length and I
think that annoys pregosian too and then
he went on this possibly impulsive
um mutineering effort which didn't
really get him anywhere and whether
that's just because he didn't get the
support that he needed within the
military ranks or didn't have a clear
enough goal
um remains to be seen and we won't know
unless we were to have a sit-down
interview with Prego in which he's not
going to give us but I think that Putin
is not going to get rid of shoigu that
this was all part of a package where he
decided that the ministry of defense was
to be in control of operations in
Ukraine and that was just the way it was
I said earlier that those pictures of
shoigu might not have been from Ukraine
I apologize K apparently it is in the
zone of the special military operation
as Russia likes to put it so of course
it is possible that in the future uh
Putin may look to reshuffle his top
military personnel but I don't think
that's going to be happening anytime
soon and certainly not because of the
events of the weekend because Vladimir
Putin looked weak enough he doesn't want
to look now as though he's bowing to
further pressure
um to reshuffle his top command